So let's talk about the nine most
commonly made mistakes
nearly everyone makes doing keto, okay?
Number one: doing it without intermittent
fasting. Now the whole purpose of keto is to fix insulin, to actually lower insulin,
to fix insulin resistance. And why
not add intermittent fasting? Because
every time you eat, you raise insulin. So
if you just do ketosis without
intermittent fasting, you may not lose
weight especially, if you're eating like
six meals a day. So it's number one.
Number two: eating when you're not hungry.
So it's like, if you're not hungry and
you eat, what's going to happen is you're
going to spike insulin again. So here you
were, you're sleeping all night, you're
burning fat, you're not hungry in the
morning, yet you eat. Well, your body was
in fat-burning all night long. So now
it's going to not be in fat-burning because
you just ate. So I would not eat unless
you're hungry, alright? Number three:
eating too much protein. So when you
consume too much protein, you can
stimulate insulin as well. So in your
mind sometimes, if you're working out, you
think, "Oh, I need more protein." But in
reality, all you need is between three to
six ounces per meal. It's much better to
consume more vegetables, a little more
fat than excessive amounts of protein,
okay? The only exception is if you're
let's say, 18-years-old and your
metabolism is super-high. You can get
away with a little bit more. Okay, number
four: omitting the vegetables. So in this
situation, if you don't consume enough
vegetables, you're not going to get the
potassium you need to form the protein
on your body parts. You're not going to
get the potassium to help regulate the
heart, the muscles, because it's a main
electrolyte. You need a tremendous amount
of potassium and that comes from
vegetables. Seven to ten cups of
vegetables every single day. You're going to
have to bite the bullet and do that. And
also, without vegetables, you can't flush
all the fat coming out through the liver.
Number five: focusing too much on the
weight or the keto sticks. So a lot of
times when you weigh yourself, you're
like, "Wow, I'm not losing much weight." But your stomach is shrinking. Realize that
you're ,when you're doing this, you are
actually converting more of your energy
to making muscle
and you're losing fat but you're
actually building up more muscle. And
muscle weighs a little bit more, so it
might not show up on the scale. So don't
sweat it. Go by your waist to see if your
waist is shrinking. And so, the same thing
with the keto sticks. If you're not in
ketosis, it doesn't mean anything because
you could be utilizing ketones. Ketones
are the byproduct of fat burning, okay? So
if you're very efficient and you're
burning up all this fat, it's not going
to show up in the urine. Number seven: too
much or too little fat. So this is the
variable that you need to really pay
attention to because if you have too
much, it could overload the gallbladder
and the liver and cause right shoulder
pain. If you don't have enough, you might
not be able to make it from one meal to
the next, so you're gonna be hungry but
as you do this, and your system is more
efficient, and you're burning more of
your fat, you'll need less dietary fat.
Okay, number eight: allowing too many
carbohydrates, okay? Now if you really
have a person to a food log and they
start looking at the hidden carbs, you're
going to find that it's like exceeding that
50-gram limit per day. I like to keep my
carbs below 30 grams every single day.
However, you don't have to worry about
calculating the vegetables because we
want you to consume a lot of vegetables,
okay? Number nine: worrying about the
cholesterol. And this is a big one
because think about it, here you are
releasing fat from the fat cells. What
does that mean? That means you're
releasing triglycerides and cholesterol.
So when you do that, what do you think is
going to happen in your blood? It's going to go up, so I put a link down below so you
can get the full understanding of what
that means. But it's not going to be a
problem, alright? Thanks for watching.
Hey, thank you so much for watching. Keep spreading the word and share this video.